[Applause]
thanks for that introduction so Matthew
tri nish
I'm a software engineer at IBM Research
and I work on the quantum computing team
there today I'm going to be talking
about quantum computing and open source
software's role in developing field
before we can get started though we need
to really talk about what a quantum
computer is because I don't think most
people actually know if you read the
tech press you probably have something
like this which is oh my God my RSA is
going to be broken the worlds on fire we
have no secure communication anymore and
that's because of in theoretical
algorithm that came out in the 90s
called Shor's algorithm which allows for
efficient factoring of prime numbers but
with the tech press and most people I've
talked to this week so far
aren't really well-informed on is that
Shor's algorithm depends on a universal
fault-tolerant quantum computer which is
still a long ways away the devices that
exist today are very noisy and have lots
of errors but another common thing I
come across and what was my personal
view of what a quantum computer was
comes from science fiction this is what
I hope the quantum computer looked like
when I started working on this field
this is from an anime I like Gundam
double-o this was the this was the
quantum computing there that housed the
super smart AI that tried to bring world
peace I like it because people are in
space and it glows but a real quantum
computer actually looks like this this
is one of the quantum computers at IBM
Research in Yorktown Heights New York
and most of the space is actually taken
up by cooling that white cylinder and
all of the gold bits are what's called a
dilution refrigerator and that gets the
temperature inside down to about 10 to
20 millikelvin so really really cold
cold with in outer space pretty much and
that's basically what all the spaces you
can see a little bit in that picture in
the upper right hand corner where you
can see the cables for the transmission
lines to send the microwave pulses down
to the chip to control it
most of it is cooling and that's because
these devices are very sensitive to
noise and any source of heat or RF or
anything is entropy in the system which
will contribute to noise in the quantum
computer the actual quantum chip is very
small just like in a you know a
classical computer the microprocessor is
the smallest bit in the laptop and
that's just some guy holding one if we
zoom in on one of those these are some
dye photos of the quantum chips these
are two publicly accessible quantum
computers that IBM produces the one on
the left is named Melbourne which is the
one hopefully I'll be able to run
something on later today and the one on
the right is called Tenerife and one on
the left is 14 qubits and the one on the
right is 5 and you can see some basic
features on these die photos the things
that are labeled Q those big dark
squares those are the actual qubits
they're constructed with something
called a Josephson Junction you can look
up what that is because I'm gonna get
into the details but that's basically
what functions is the qubit and then
between the qubits you see those things
labeled B those are resonators that
allow for coupling between qubits for
multi qubit operation and then you have
other resonators that go out which are
for reading data out and sending signals
into the qubits and while all of these
devices are very sophisticated and
pretty cool there's still a lot of
limitations with them the biggest thing
is noise even with that fancy dilution
refrigerator these devices are very
susceptible to noise and the longer you
run operations on it the longer you
accumulate noise so that leads to things
like decoherence where you can only run
a certain number of operations on a
qubit before it loses its quantum state
and you just get random noise as your
output there are other things like the
number of qubits this is 14 this is 5
could you imagine if you only had a 5
bit computer and you could only run
operations for like 50 microseconds
before it broke apart and you couldn't
use it anymore so these devices still
have a lot of limitations
but why am I talking about this then if
there are all these limited limitations
and that's because it's actually a
really exciting time in the field of
quantum computing and to just give some
perspective I thought putting this
timeline up showing some of the key
events from the history of quantum
computing would be useful I borrowed the
slide from a colleague so I don't
pretend to understand the significance
of each point but it's useful for
outlining the broader trends in the
history of quantum computing so you can
see in the 30s there was the theoretical
underpinnings of quantum mechanics and
then in the 1970s into the early 80s
there was the theory of quantum
information basically using quantum
mechanics to perform to store
information and perform computation on
it and it was mainly theoretical into
the 80s into the early 90s where you had
algorithms being developed with this new
field you had conferences on the topic
and then in labs they started being able
to replicate this theory and start
building qubits in the 90s small small
single qubit systems that lasted
fractions of the time they last today
and it was the domain of being in the
lab up until a couple a few years ago
when IBM decided to take one of the
machines they had built a five qubit
device in the lab and open it up to the
world they put it behind a public API
let anyone sign up for credentials and
submit programs to this quantum computer
and that really changed it because now
it's generally accessible to all of us
before you would need basically a PhD
and in a job where you could work in a
lab where you could afford a dilution
refrigerator and have a supply of liquid
helium to keep it cool and now you can
you know sit on your laptop anywhere in
the world and submit a job to a quantum
computer and experiment with these
devices as they're becoming more
sophisticated and that's really where
the role of open source started to come
in and where the project I work in came
in because with open access you needed a
tool to be able to program it yes
there's an API but how do you you know
write in a fish and quantum program for
it and that's where the project I work
on comes in which is called quiz kit
quiz kid is specifically a cool
an SDK designed to work with no noisy
intermediate scale quantum computers
which is basically just a catch-all term
that says for the devices around today
moving into the future with you know
small number of qubits where there's
still noise there's no fault tolerance
you can't basically not the theoretical
perfect quantum computer but the the
real-world devices that exist today and
for the near future this toolkit is
licensed under Apache 2 and we wrote it
to be back-end agnostic which means it
can run on any quantum device or
simulator out there we include batteries
for with it so you can run it on IBM Q
devices because it's being developed at
IBM but also with local simulators if
you don't want to submit your jobs to an
actual device you can just run it
locally with the simulator and like a
lot of open source projects it's built
up of components and we decided to name
the elements or the components of quiz
kit after the classical elements the one
we're going to be spending most of the
time on in this talk is called tera
which is the base layer and provides the
interface between the hardware and
software then there's the air element
which is the high-performance C++
simulator that also allows for noise
modeling the Aqua element is basically
for algorithms it provides a library
interface in Python so if you don't want
to deal with the low-level programming
of a quantum computer it basically gives
you a function here you can run this
quantum algorithm give me the inputs
I'll give you the output and then
there's Ignace which has not been
released yet but it's for dealing with
noise and errors but as I said we're
going to be concentrating on tera and
tera is the base layer it provides the
software interface between the quantum
computers and any end-user who wants to
write a program with it you can kind of
think of it like a combination of an ISA
and a compiler because it provides both
the api's for building quantum programs
and also
the tools to build those quantum
programs for a specific back-end whether
that be a simulator or an actual device
and this was written all in Python which
is great for me because I'm a big fan of
programming in Python and it was at this
point in the presentation I wanted to
show you an example of how you would
actually use tera to solve a real
problem or a hypothetical problem at
least but before I could do that I
thought it was important to give some
background on quantum information from a
high level I'm not pretending this is
going to be exhaustive primer on quantum
information and I hope it's not too
complex I can I'll have some links to
more information at the end because I'm
not covering every aspect of it but just
to give a feel for how you can use a
quantum computer from a theoretical
standpoint and to start we need to talk
about the qubit or the quantum bit the
easiest way to think about a quantum bit
or qubit is using the Bloch sphere which
is that sphere on the right you can
think of the state of the qubit as being
any point along the surface of that
sphere and when you perform operations
on a qubit you're basically moving the
vector which is represented by that
orange line around the surface of the
qubit just like a classical bit you can
have a 0 state which is the arrow
pointing up and a 1 state the arrow
pointing down don't you don't have to
worry too much about that notation
that's called rocket or direct direct
notice notation and that just means it's
a vector and when you have a qubit you
can have the state as whatever based on
the operations but when you want to get
the data out of it you have to measure
from the qubit and the measurement
occurs along the z axis the up and down
and it will always be a 0 or a 1
depending on whether it goes up or it
goes down and once you measure you've
collapsed the state and it's gone and
you'd have to reconstruct it from
scratch yet
and you perform the operations on the
qubit using what are called quantum
logic gates the example I put here is
the ex gate which is the simplest one to
think about you can think of the ex gate
on the Bloch sphere as a hundred and
eighty degree rotation over the x axis
so if you had a qubit at state zero like
on the Left diagram you apply the ex
gate it rotates over X and then it's
down to one it's also commonly called
the quantum not operation because that's
basically what it does when it's at the
base of state and there are a lot of
quantum gates out there there are ones
for all of the axes rotating over them
there are ones for arbitrary rotation
over different axes and we're really not
going to get into all of the different
gates that are out there but the other
takeaway that I wanted to mention here
although I'm not going to really go into
it in more detail is that all of these
operations can be represented by unitary
matrices which just is just means that
these can all be represented as a matrix
that you multiply by your quantum state
and that performs the transform so this
all of this can be represented as linear
algebra and I don't really want to get
more into it because I'm pretty terrible
at linear algebra but what this also
means is that all computation and a
quantum computer is reversible so all of
these gates are reversible so for
example here if you apply X again it
goes back to its original state and that
holds true for both these simple gates
and ones that are more complex which
will come up later when we look at a
real example but we've only looked at
when a qubit is at 0 or a 1 what happens
when it's in the middle this is called
superposition and it's one of the one of
the key differences between a quantum
system a quantum computer and a
classical computer is that you can have
a qubit in a state where it's prepared
deterministically but it behaves
randomly and that randomness is inherent
to nature so for example if we put a
qubit at the state there where the
vector is pointing at a positive 1 on
the x axis
and not any vertical along the Z when
you measure this cubit it will have a
50/50 chance of being either a zero or
one because you measure along the z axis
and it'll either collapse up claps down
and you'll either get a 0 or a 1 and the
gate for putting something in
superposition is called the Hadamard
gate the atom or gate is basically a
rotation of 180 degrees around the X
plus the z axis I know it's a little
abstract hopefully this diagram makes it
clear but you apply a Hadamard let's say
it's at the zero basis state you rotate
over X plus C which is like a diagonal
moving and then it goes to X plus 1 so
is it the Hadamard gate and it's used
for putting things in superposition the
other thing we haven't talked about is
the phase because all of these examples
we've been looking at it at either 0 or
1 going up and down there's another
dimension to look at it if you look at
this diagram with the angles you could
be thinking we were thinking about it
with just that theta there is supposed
to be there is that other dimension and
we can't use that for actual measurement
because we read along the z axis but you
can encode information in that phase and
then use a Hadamard to rotate to get it
along the basis state and you play
tricks like this with your quantum
programs to perform computation and code
extra information that you couldn't in a
traditional binary system and just to
demonstrate the effect that a Hadamard
gate has on phase because everything is
reversible if you had a qubit at the
zero state you apply a Hadamard to it
it's at you can consider that the 0 plus
1 state or positive x on the key on the
Bloch sphere and then you apply a
Hadamard again it goes to zero but what
if the Hadamard is at one pointing down
if you rotate a law across X plus Z it
goes minus X because it's pointing down
the other way
so then you can think of that as 0-1 and
you can see there the phase is different
which is that minus sign so then when
you apply a Hadamard again it will
rotate down instead of up and that's
just a math way of thinking about the
phase instead of keep trying to
conceptualize a three-dimensional sphere
in your head when you're applying
operations and the last gate I wanted to
talk about is a two qubit gate which is
called the controlled-not gate or the
controlled ex gate which is basically
saying if the control qubit is at a 1
state you just flip the target qubit
it's basically an if but quanta so you
can see in this example when the control
qubit is at zero nothing happens to the
target is the same on either end of the
gate on the bottom one when it's one you
just flip it and so the coefficients
flip like a rotation across the X so if
it was at the zero state it would be at
the one state and vice versa and then
you can put all of this together to
build quantum circuits which is a way of
visualizing a quantum program and in
this diagram you can see all of the
gates and all of the all of the bits and
you basically just read it left to right
to show the operations that you apply in
sequence on a specific qubit and this is
just for showing dependency and
operation not actual timing and then you
can see right there the last thing on
there that I haven't talked about is the
measure which just shows that you're
measuring the qubit and reading it to a
classical bit which are the double lines
on the bottom and this is a way you can
visualize performing the operations and
sequins on qubits to perform computation
and with that that was all the
background I wanted to give so I wanted
to talked about an example problem
something that we can actually solve on
a real device today which is called the
Bernstein vaz Irani algorithm
and I I know the numbers and the letters
are a bit scary so it's easier to think
about it like this so let's say you have
an Oracle and the Oracle has a secret
bit string and you don't know what that
is you can ask the Oracle a question
which you give it a bit string it will
give you the dot product output so let's
say the secret is all ones if you give
it the bit string 0 1 0 0 you would get
back 0 1 0 0 and the goal is to find out
what that secret is by only asking with
an input bit string does that make sense
to everyone
does anyone have any idea how you would
solve that with like just a computer
today brute-force yeah yeah and that's
actually pretty pretty much the right
answer the ideal way to solve this is
you just for loop so you make a bit mask
for each bit in the length of your bit
string you just loop over it and you say
okay so you've you I know you have a bit
bit string of length 4 I'll just give
you one in each position and then I'll
know whether that's a 1 or a 0 based on
the dot product of it so the ideal case
for a classical computer is om because
you just loop over each bit with a bit
mask but with a quantum Oracle you can
do that in one single call to the Oracle
and the other thing to call out here is
the the bottom bit that temp bit
remember when I said all operations are
reversible if you have something like
this where you want the secret bit
string regardless of what your input is
you'd lose the input information on the
output so you couldn't reverse it and a
way to work around that is by having
that extra bit where you can encode the
lost information and that's what that
template is for and the way you
construct a quantum Oracle is actually
really simple it's just a bunch of
cenotes so in this case
we have four cubits and our secret bit
string is 1 0 0 1 so we just put a C
naught where it should be a 1 and I
picked 1 0 0 1 on in particular because
mdns doesn't matter it's a palindrome
things if you put something in the
middle and it's not a palindromic hurts
your head when you start having to think
about mdns just like on a real computer
so this is the implementation but how
does it work and it uses something
called phase kickback which is you can
kind of think of it like a trick so
let's say we've got two qubits one at
zero one at one and we apply a Hadamard
to it so they're put in superposition
you can think of that state as I was
talking about before a zero plus one and
zero minus one just you know the two
qubits and those are their states but
it's all linear algebra so you can just
expand it so it becomes 0 0 minus 0 1
plus 1 0 minus 1 1 this you know hope
it's not too much like a math lecture
and then if we apply a C not the
definition of a C naught we had before
was if it's 1 you flip it so we just do
that
so what was before and now becomes we
just flip it when it's a 1 so it becomes
minus 1 0 plus 1 1 and then it's just
linear algebra again so you can factor
it and when you factor it you realize
that the phase on that first qubit has
flipped and that's the phase kickback
the the phase is kicking back from the
target to the control and then if you
were to apply a Hadamard again to it you
would get 1 1 as your output which is a
bit counterintuitive when you think
about it because if you were thinking in
a classical computer if you had an if
condition on a bit the the control would
not ever be affected by the output bit
different in a quantum computer so when
we put everything together we can use
this phase kick back
for our Oracle so we just replaced the
Oracle function with our C naught
implementation and then using phase
kickback we'll always get the right
answer or at least hopefully and now I
can actually show you running this on a
real quantum computer or at least
hopefully we'll find out so this is this
legible to everyone especially those in
the back just give me a thumbs up if
it's good okay so this is using quiz
Katara to define the circuit to start so
we start by outlining our registers so
we say we we build a quantum register
with four bits
named Q the temper at M preju stir of
one one bit one qubit called temp and
then a classical register of length four
for our result which we call res and we
just outline those then the next step is
to build our Oracle function and we just
use a for loop for that so we define the
secret bit string of 1 0 0 1 or you
could put whatever that is in an actual
integers that 9 or is my binary to
whatever
1 0 0 1 we define a circuit called the
Oracle and then we just apply C X's when
it's 1 so that's what that for loop does
we're just doing a bit shift for each
iteration of the loop and saying if it's
1 c XA and then we build that circuit
then we build the rest of the circuit we
embed that little Oracle bit in the
bigger circuit that I drew so we apply
the XK to the temp bit to make it 1 for
phase kick back then we apply the
Hadamard gates to everything we add our
Oracle we apply the hata margins again
and then we measure and we build that
circuit and then we can draw it to
verify that we can draw it to verify
what we just entered in Python matches
our expectation of what we want our
algorithm to do
and hopefully this looks like what I put
in slides because I copied the code but
so now we have a Python object that
represents our circuit that we can run
on devices so to start we'll run it on a
simulator so we use the air component of
quiz kit to say what are our backends
available and there are three simulators
there they all do different things for
looking at different state of different
aspects of a quantum computer we're just
going to use the chasm simulator which
gives us a result like a number like is
it 1 or 0 you can read the documentation
for air to see what the other ones do
but it's not worth getting into and of
course live demo curse I run it on the
simulator and it fails because of course
it does this was the part that was
supposed to work I'm not gonna sit here
and debug it for you I have an example
where I show it working but in the ideal
case the execute command there takes in
a circuit and an output device it will
compile the circuit to work with
whatever the device specifications are
which in a simulator there are it
accepts everything and then it will run
it and give you the result and then I'd
be plotting the result here and show
that a hundred percent of the time the
histogram shows one zero zero one in a
theoretical case with no noise it always
works and I'll show you that because I
have a notebook saved with the proper
answer I have no idea where this stack
trace is coming from it's looking like
you can't spawn the simulator whatever
now comes the fun part where we can run
this on a real quantum computer so you
know load my credentials and see which
backends are available we've got three
devices available we've got IBM QX 4
which is the 5 qubit one from the
earlier slide
I've got IBM q16 Melbourne which is the
14 qubit device from the slide and then
that's a simulator that runs in a
supercomputer so you can simulate more
qubits and what I can run on my laptop
which is apparently zero but and then we
can use some fancy things for jupiter
notebooks to see the state of these
systems so this is just querying the api
i might take a second because conference
Wi-Fi anyone torrenting on the Wi-Fi
it's Tuesday night back home but I made
sure that the device would be up not in
a maiden in cycle and they said they
gave me a priority access but this isn't
even sending anything to the device this
is just there we go
this is just querying the devices for
information so we can use this to see
the state of the just an overview of the
machines we have access to so these are
the two quantum computers that we can
run the run the program on the one on
the left is the 14 qubit one and you can
see the coupling between the qubits
which are the lines so those are the
qubits we can run multi qubit operations
like a C not on and then you can see the
coherence times which are those numbers
on the bottom which tell you how many
how long you have to run operations
before you're going to likely lose
quantum state and just get random noise
on your output and you can also see how
many jobs are ahead of you waiting in
the queue and now comes the moment of
truth to try to run it on one of those
devices and I was told I was given
priority access so I should be able to
jump the queue unless someone else with
priority access has filled up the queue
so let's see if this works
so it it's compiling the job to fit the
device to make sure that it you know
matches the coupling map that's what it
says it's doing let's see if it lets me
jump the jobs run pretty quickly because
you what
oh there sorry the question was how long
did the jobs normally take to run the
answer is they're normally pretty quick
I mean your coherence time is on the
order of tens of microseconds so each
individual ron has to fit within that
time otherwise you'll just get random
noise but the other thing to consider is
because it's such a noisy system and
there's no error correction we could get
a wrong answer which actually thank you
for pointing that out because something
I forgot to mention is that you see that
shots argument we're gonna run this
experiment 1,024 times so we can have a
plot of what what our result is every
single time and of course yes there's an
admin in the queue in front of me
running so I'm in queue number 94 which
is not great because I'm supposed to
have priority access and be number one
what it's I think it's a number on the
left but but luckily I thought this was
gonna be a problem because I've seen a
similar talk and they had the same exact
issue so I saved the results so we can
just scroll down and we can see the
simulator results so we run it a
thousand twenty four times in the
simulator and we always get the answer
one zero zero one which is what we
wanted it's a bit anti-climatic when you
have to go back after it didn't work but
and then we can run these on the real
quantum computers and the first one I
ran on the five qubit one because I just
sat last night and waited in the queue
for my
and you can see here the developer real
device is very noisy so we ran it a
thousand 24 times and we only had a 46%
chance of getting the right answer when
we ran it for real and then the rest of
them were noise and then I also ran it
on the Melbourne device and it was
actually noisier which makes sense
because there are more qubits there's
more things going on more sources of
noise at least in my head it makes sense
I'm sure the theoretical that
experimental physicists will disagree
with me but so at least this can
hopefully show how you can use a quantum
computer to solve at least a
hypothetical problem that the Oracle
problem is not a really good problem how
many times in your day job do you have
to go write a program for a function
that has a secret number that you can
only query with a single bit string with
and get the dot product it's very
constructed in fact it's constructed
specifically to show the quantum
advantage here it's constructed to show
that you can do in one operation on a
quantum computer what would take n
operations on a classical computer but
it's not a real-world thing but it
hopefully gets you thinking about how
you can approach problems differently
with a quantum computer to get this kind
of speed up and then I'll go back to my
slides to talk about a little bit about
the role of open source in quantum
computing so the thing that's really
interesting is a lot of the tools for
dealing with quantum computers are open
source most of them are licensed under
Apache - probably for patent reasons
because this is all brand-new stuff and
open source is being used to foster
collaboration because it's not just one
group of people that can build these
things they're incredibly complicated
devices that are pushing our
understanding of physics so leveraging
open source allows collaboration across
multiple institutions and people all
over the world to figure out how we can
use these devices we have today and also
how to push the software of the future
to
run things on these quantum computers
and the other thing that I find really
interesting is that it's we've learned
lessons from the development of
classical computers I remember reading
and books about how when classical
computers first came out no one thought
anything of software they just gave it
away for free and then someone realized
they could make money and then
proprietary software and free software
in the whole history but with quantum
computing we're starting from
you could argue from before day one
especially based on live demo that
everything is open-source to begin with
all of these tools for developing that
are open source so if you're interested
in this field even though the technology
isn't the most mature yet you can still
experiment with it see how everything
works learn about it
I don't have a background in
experimental physics I was I worked on
cloud software before I started working
on this but because it's all open-source
I was able to dig in and at least pick
up a little bit of knowledge or at least
I hope I have and the other thing that I
find really awesome is just the sheer
number of tools the longer I've worked
in this space the longer the more and
more open-source tools I've seen I
highlighted a few of the bigger names if
you search for open source quantum
computing just as lengths there a lot of
them are actually pretty similar to quiz
kit they're just developed by different
companies that are building quantum
computers there are exceptions there
Project Q there is one from Microsoft
which is called Q sharp and that's their
approach to a quantum programming
language which is like C sharp and needs
Visual Studio and I never touch it and
then but you can just do a search I
typed that topic into github and there
were over 300 projects that have tagged
themselves as being quantum computing
and this is day one basically and it's
really really exciting to me to see that
everyone is embracing open source for a
field that's just getting started so to
bring this all together I just want to
say that like a lot of people ask why
are we developing quantum computers and
it's not to replace classical computers
at least any time soon it's to solve the
problems we
can't solve with the classical computer
there there are a lot of problems that
are very difficult or next to impossible
to solve with a classical computer
unless you have infinite time or
infinite resources and classical
computing at least theoretically shows
us that we can solve these problems with
a with a quantum computer so developing
this technology and experimenting with
it is to try to solve problems we can't
solve today but it's still very early
for the technology the the key takeaway
I want everyone to have though is that
quantum computing isn't just in a lab
today it's accessible to everyone
everyone can sign up and submit jobs to
a quantum computer and all of the
software to do that is open source and I
think that's really cool so with that I
put up some links where these slides are
some more information about quiz kit
that link at the bottom is quiz kit
tutorials it's a bunch of ipython
notebooks that explain concepts in
quantum computing using quiz kit and
basically kind of like what my demo was
supposed to be but different things that
are a lot more advanced and going to all
of the information and then also if
anyone is interested and wants to sign
up you can use that quantum experience
link to sign up to get access to the
quantum computers and submit jobs and
experiment and play around with it so
with that that's all I had for prepared
material are there any questions so
we've got two questions there and the
runner is gonna are they still
developing like new quantum algorithms
and has open source helped to make new
innovations so the there are still new
algorithms under development that's the
field of very heavy research I'd say
that's more the field of academic
research right now so there's published
papers on the topic and that's that's
where the developments and that are
happening there are libraries for
established quantum algorithms that
exists today that are open source
well the ocular thing that I talked
about earlier that's an example of that
but I
because quantum computing is so new and
so different I don't think open-source
has had time to take to you know show
its true advantage in collaboration on
developing new algorithms yet because
not enough people understand how to
program it except for people who have
you know PhDs and math and quantum
information theory just wonder any
people out there started using quantum
computing at the moment for real cases
you mean for like a business use case or
okay I'm not sure what I'm allowed to
talk about there there are people using
it but it's mostly like research trying
to figure out how they will use the
devices in the future they're promising
fields like quantum chemistry where this
is being looked at and actively
researched to solve real problems yes
and as he said in the financial world
there are also people trying to use
quantum computing
there's a guy in right there patiently
waiting which language is used to
control the hardware part of quantum
computer is this new assembly so it's a
bit more complicated than just a
language because all of these operations
are being performed by microwave pulses
it's like interfacing with basically
like lab equipment to generate like
arbitrary waveform generators to send
the pulses so there's a software stack
that translates from what what quiz gets
sends to those in your definition of
quantum Oracle you used arrays as one of
argument actually it's not used in the
Oracle right can you show the the
definition of quantum Oracle no no no
the code the code or the code yeah
it's above I think you know so what why
you use this raise the ransom yeah it's
not used in the Oracle it's just
transferred those are the the classical
bits the classical register where we
store the results yes yes but it's only
used later in the code if you see the
because because the Oracle we're
defining as a its own function so we
define a circuit object for just that
function and then we build a separate
circuit object which is like the bigger
circuit and we embed that in the smaller
one so it just it's like a combination
of well you can add circuits together
and it'll just add the operations to the
end of the current of the circuit you're
working with so this this line bv +
oracle takes the operations we defined
in that oracle circuit object and embeds
it in this bv object okay does that make
sense yeah kind of and the second
question is there any research to reduce
the noise in the hardware yeah by the
way kudos to the runner I'm a
professional ignorant so I ask questions
for a living you say that you have a can
you share the journey you say that you
came from the cloud computing world I
mean I recognize had a mile from my days
of calculus but that's 100 years over or
something like that if I want to employ
someone to explore the basics of quantum
which would be the timeline that I
should get to someone to say okay if I
want to go and I don't know go into
business into the financial world it's a
six month project it's a six years
project do we need to know it
theoretical physics give us just a
totally high-level con I mean I I
understand this talk and I've been
working in
this since August I transferred
departments from working on cloud
computing to this back in the beginning
of August I don't pretend to understand
all the maths and I feel for myself
that's a limitation when trying to
develop my own algorithms I can pair it
one from a textbook or a paper from 1993
but I can't develop my own I don't have
an answer for trying what the timeline
would be for trying for that skill set
but for picking up the Python and
learning the basics of how circuits work
and that kind of stuff I was able to
pick it up in a few months
personally I have more or less a
theoretical question about the
complexity classes involved here what's
the relationship between classical
algorithms and these quantum algorithms
I know an example from the 1960s where
you know logistic machines and there are
variants like vector machines where you
can encode it arbitrarily many bits in
one register and have ended our
operations and some algorithms are
running faster there as in a classical
machine or in a classical Turing machine
and it would be interesting to know the
relationship what's the potential speed
of by this quantum and related to
classical algorithms yeah I'm not sure
I'm able to answer that I did have a
backup slide that I put together about
complexity which was something I didn't
want to get into which is the other
principle in quantum mechanics that
makes quantum computing unique which is
entanglement which is you can have two
bits that behave independently random
but correlated and that leads to an
exponential growth and complexity as the
number of entangled qubits grows but I
don't think that really answers your
question yeah okay
yeah sorry guys I have to coach but just
out of time but can I get you all to
please give a round of applause for
Gracie punished
[Applause]